it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
gin what jersey is that i'll explain
all these i'll explain oh hello
all explained people call me your before
too because how i guess the way i talk
sometimes yeah you really get excited
about things although when you drink
chicken gets pretty exciting i'm
drinking though dude okay cheers
cheers
do you ever think that like um i went to
the zoo and i saw these [__] rhesus
monkeys on a tiny island in the zoo and
there was this monkey no rhesus oh yes
and racist and they were they're all
these giant carp were around them so it
was a moat basically and they were on
that island for their life i thought to
myself
that's literally
10 square feet by 10 square yards
i wonder if that's what hell is for some
people do you come back as a monkey and
you can't really tell anybody like same
[__] different day [__]
i don't either or that's like a town
that's like an apartment in new york
yeah but if that's the only place you
are yeah
basically i have a lot uh apartment in
new york during lockdown yes like six
hours for the rest of your life though
yeah oh i know monkeys live 30 years
i don't know what they live but they're
monkeys though right they're monkeys so
they have food like if they're in nature
like yeah they have freedom to swing
from tree to tree but it's not like
they're jumping from one freaking force
to the next yeah they kind of they don't
migrate that's why she's chilling one
tree i worked i actually tracked
orangutans as you know through the
forest you know what they do all day eat
and and sleep and
they're alone like the males are spend
all their time alone yes and those
stupid monkeys only live 20 years right
yeah you know 27. enjoy your time dude
it's a long time you hang out with your
bros like it's pretty you know what i'm
gonna pitch it the other way see you're
ha glass half empty you have a glass
full no stress nothing no money to be
made you just get yourself predators
these houses chill with the boys yeah
well my nuts out i think
i'll tell you what i think
i bet you in some in some zoos like if
there's an eagle around and you're a
monkey in open air you got to be [__]
careful sure sure see if any eagles have
grabbed monkeys you've seen it we saw
videos yeah we know about that you've
done this three times in the zoo how
many times does zoo do zeus because yeah
i'll answer that so zero right because
let's say you're in downtown san diego
yeah not a lot of free eagles floating
around there are there baldies not a lot
are they named the last time you saw an
eagle
just randomly in a metropolitan if i saw
an eagle i'd drop a baby you know what i
mean like it's rare pretty [__] you
saw a giant golden eagle he was like
what the [__] that's an eagle so to your
point have you ever seen one
uh i seen a i've seen an eagle but like
i was in were you driving down i was in
montana yes yeah driving on a deserted
road yeah you weren't
chicago and that story i just told you
and there's downtown
about seeing an eagle in montana
no it might have been something i saw on
youtube and now i'm saying i saw it so
that could be lying about that i don't
even know so this is what's frustrating
we asked jim hey bring up bald eagles
killing uh monkeys in the zoo right
that's not a problem that they're
worried about right so yeah another
point for the monkey i think it happens
more than you know i couldn't find
anything but i don't think so i couldn't
find it thank you i think there's
nothing those lose monkeys to eagles all
the time i said it out loud but jen
before we were on the weird monkey rant
uh the jersey this safe is it a family
jersey oh so it's it's a silly saying
but my my close group of friends that i
told you guys before we've been together
for like
over 20 25 years we still like do
holidays birthdays together uh-huh and
everyone so we call it no a lot of them
are this is good they're married wait
brian no i'm not saying it so instead of
calling it family we're friends and
family so they want to do family
but the reason why this jersey is
beautiful is because remember i told you
guys my friend passed away from cancer
yes so we always wear it every now and
then his name is okay i was gonna make
fun of jersey yeah but not anymore yeah
yeah i don't need that because i if it
wasn't for your friend to pass away if
it was just for your friends
i was getting
i had a bonfire going with a spit
right through your mouth out your
[__] and just turn you slowly we're
going to spin now
you brought cancer into it and we both
you took the wind out of our sails yeah
so i was going to say that that jersey
frustrates me
because his family i know i got to put
the family got to put the fire out
all good gin i have one question yeah
please it's just a question though first
why is it not sewn in nope
so
there's a question you and your friends
had these made and then you guys when
you go on vacation do you wear those
sometimes together all together
we do it on special occasions yeah and i
was just like thinking about himself
you're all the same no yeah yeah i get
it
but but let me ask you this jim so when
you guys go to like let's say disneyland
or to dinner do you guys all show up in
new jersey they wanted to do it at
disneyland before but we didn't do it
yeah that's no so it's only one question
that's a shop rule
we don't wear the same thing at
disneyland unless it's father-son then
it's fine then it's cute then it's a
hard time
adults and someone brought a flask we
can't dress the same i'm with you buddy
on that now have you ever worn the same
jerseys when you've done a vegas trip
you mean
us
yeah yeah that's who i'm talking about
no no only for our special friends
occasions that's another so like if you
guys have like oh whatever squid game
two's coming out come on ask for a party
does everybody show up in the jerseys no
no no but when you're kind of cool we
probably weren't like twice together or
one what's happening me and bryan don't
have that many friends i know and we
wish we were part of this property
we're lucky yeah we're super lucky you
guys are this close yeah all my
brian's friends of mine literally have
scattered yeah yeah yeah they don't have
jerseys and i've asked them to wear it
they'd be very mean about it i i spoke
to somebody who's very successful today
and they said you'll appreciate this and
uh they're a boss they run a lot of [__]
and they said uh
i suffer from depression sometimes what
gets you depressed you said this to this
success no they said okay
they said um i uh i suffer from
depression i said why i said
because
success brought with me uh uh the fact
that
even if i get a cold
people who work for me want me to die
like they they i don't feel well they
they almost want like it's like
it's like is your friend bill gates i've
seen a darker side of humanity when
you're the boss people kind of resent
you for it hate you for it and also
you're constantly being let down that
might be what the best way to play put
it yeah it depends what his business is
like if he has hundreds of employees i'm
sure you're not gonna have a well oh
interesting i know is that funny so i
would have thought
it's a different game right different
game you told me that from the job and
funny though because i would have said i
you natural think hey and it's actually
well i figure you don't have a lot of
female friends you know so that's why i
said that and also when i say very
powerful
but she must also have
probably her line of work
um assuming it's not entertainment or
anything like that where there's like a
like your peers in this group community
right she's probably has employees they
have to do jobs
entertainment like production but you're
talking about something like if it's
like uh you know like a major promotion
house or a production yeah i think
agency or lawyer yeah well what i think
when you're a big producer you know or
whatever and you're you're responsible
for all the money hiring and and then
managing a a set do i know you have i
met the person i think so
but when you manage uh when you manage
all those people what happens is there's
this
there's a lot of infighting there's a
lot of like jockeying for power there's
a lot of like this is my point of view
and and i'm gonna take your i'm gonna
try to [__] you over and i think then
you have to become
the equalizing dragon you gotta shut
down some people's ideas and stuff like
that yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's interesting
yeah heavy lies the crown that's all
have it lies the ground yes probably
constantly putting out fires i think too
in entertainment if you are like a
producer director right like i'm sure a
lot of those people underneath you want
your gig right so they're also
you know they're pitching ideas and you
can't take all ideas you have a vision
and then you gotta squash their vision
and i'm sure it upsets them like that'd
be a nightmare man it is a nightmare
it's it's you're always putting out
fires like though i say the president
united states when he makes a decision
he pisses off fifty percent of the
people and makes fifty percent of the
people uh
semi-happy when buying skates it's
ninety-nine percent
well that's that's a whole different
thing you got to do something right yeah
yeah you can do something though right
like something
yeah it's wrong do something yeah i
wouldn't want to be in those meetings
yes how's my approval ratings well uh he
doesn't he you know yeah i don't think
he's coherent for that stuff
i don't know but that yeah that's that's
uh
you get to yeah but i think but i think
if you yeah the president's a different
animal i think if you if you run a
business
like especially here it's like
everyone's trying to achieve something
so there's like this kind of
motivational like atmosphere that's what
i try and build you know what i'm saying
well i don't know what's trying to step
on anyone's toes it's more like
i think everyone's spread so thin it's
like all right who's taking care of this
who's taking care of this like
i've always booked
you know
the thick boy besides the shop show we
have some guests on but the thick boy
business model is based and the
same was on showtime is based off guest
so the show rides and dies with guests
right so it's like it's just been my
personal connections texting guys that's
how we've booked it since i was showtime
it's all my doing
it it gets exhausting so finally we
hired a booker she has connection with
liz she has the truth yeah just
it's a nightmare yeah i'm in that right
yeah it's a horrible and then there
things come up and it's like
you know yeah that's a beast it's a
[__] it's a full-time job just
allocating that stuff we're like i don't
have to worry about this thank god yeah
that's all it is yeah and being able to
trust somebody to get it done yeah
that's not easy yeah it's a [__] um
what what whiskey we drinking today come
on daddy yeah the only one that matters
tiger thick
i'm i'm hearing through the grapevines i
tried to get some you guys are sold out
you get online or if you're a certain uh
place in texas still have some i'm still
having trouble getting it yeah you know
why yep we just but we just got a big
shipment daddy just got a big old ship
it's tasty as [__] it is nice that's
tasty
that's a good you know who loves it and
i just send them cases is uh bert
crasher loves it i love it yeah i bet
it's a beautiful whiskey yeah he drank
it with the the boys that were on the
are you garbage boys around the pod and
he has drinks he's like let's drink
shops i love this [__] right so you
throw another bottle i know at least a
bottle i think he's trying to cut back
hey hey mark what are you doing over
there
what are you doing oh okay
he's got those hot hospital pants on
mark
those are some of mark's favorite the
the nurse pam they're very easy to throw
yeah mark rodgers not covered in cat
piss currently so that's always a
positive your cat pisses everywhere
yeah one male cat and he pees everywhere
and is that that's the mark in their
territory yeah and it's my fault for
like anything you leave on the floor or
something like that it's like oh you
throw something off it's like oh [__]
you you know suitcases okay like
anything that's open on the floor
they're like oh yeah it's mine
we're letting people know
you know he poops in the same place
every morning out right next to the
litter box yeah cats are [__] yeah
and only the male right because you know
your cat does not give a [__] about you
right isn't that the case with cats it's
awful
i mean mark's balls dipping cats i know
but is it but i i don't think they
really do care about you do they they
like being pet but it's awesome
i would say that's a more interesting
philosophical question of like what does
that mean i think uh they wouldn't have
any remorse about killing but do i think
that my cat has genuine affection for me
and knows who i am and can differentiate
me yes here's the thing mark yeah you're
the guy in the strip club who fell in
love with a girl named cinnamon and you
think
you're the specialist
yeah that's what it is
i would say
the cat's playing dude
write that as a joke yeah yeah but okay
here's the thing
that is exactly
here's the exact same behavior as you
know when a guy connects to a lion for
example like there's some of these guys
out in the reserves in south africa and
they go out there the lions come up and
like they're so excited to see him yes
now the lions aren't dependent he's not
giving them food for example so
lions are more social compared to other
cats yes they see you as part of this
tribe and they rub on you and do certain
things like you're part of this in group
so
that's a little bit different because
lions are pack animals pride animals
cats indoors they communicate the way
dogs do that way there's a whole
language of aggression and one of the
things when you when you work with lions
you have to let them
check you out and greet you you have
there's a whole protocol that you have
to allow whereas the tiger is very very
different that way but lions are here's
the other thing mark you know if you
like let's say you fell and uh hit your
head yeah on the ground in your
apartment and heaven forbid you passed
away you know your cat's going to eat
your lips off right right that wouldn't
bother that
because i just want to pass away if i'm
dead i'd want my cat to survive
and he wouldn't have he would there just
wouldn't be a moral compass aspect he's
like well i eat animals all the time
like sorry i'm trapped inside this house
like i i hope it would eat other things
first if it was outside no no
first
there was a guy who was a scientist who
was on talking about that he had a
praying mantis and some other beetle
something like that and
he spent so much time with them that
they started to equate them with food
and they they would like and then they
became for he was trying to get them to
be somewhat friendly with each other so
he did all this stuff with you yeah and
so they were actually psyched of course
but they they're singing trying to see
if there was intelligence and insects
and this idea of yeah they recognize
reward and and so
they ended up like they would come right
on to him they would climb onto but they
wouldn't climb on someone else yeah
right so there's a familiarity so he had
this whole thing about these animals
and uh the i guess one of the water
bottles something fell by accident on
one of unlike the beetle or something
right no it it burst his abdomen and
there was some there was some stuff that
came out of his abdomen but it was still
alive and these two friends the other
insect was like
and just [__] dove on that thing's
stomach and just started eating him
alive
this isn't bug's life like they're not
gonna talk to each other they don't give
a [__] they was like you're oh you
you're dying and your stomach's open i'm
gonna eat the [__] out of you yeah did
that scientist go oh this isn't a disney
movie by that's what he did this
he was like shame on me
yeah and i i would assume there's just
like it's like a smelling a delicious
meal you don't mean the guts of a
praying mantis or something or beetle
sounds delicious but also counterpoint
to that there you do hear some stories
about owners being eaten by their dogs
like there was a famous you know what
are you going there huh you're going
there like dude
team cat over here am i right
team cat
that is if the inverse doesn't and i
love both dogs and cats but a woman was
eaten by her dogs like out in a walk you
know yeah that's a rare thing with a
crazy dog but like cats
that a cat eats an owner
that's rare as well
yeah well they she was probably an
[__] and those dogs were probably she
just adopted a bunch of wild dogs
there's a lot of trust with a cat is
what i'll say so it's like you could
attribute it to whatever well they were
probably alone for a long time i think
what they can well i think no they're
out in the woods i think the difference
is like on a walk what they what
scientists say i i don't [__] know
dude i grew up with cats i'm allergic to
them yeah but
they like your cats we can take and put
in my house and they don't give a [__]
as long as there's food and water a dog
if you've been with that dog for five or
six years i take that dog from your
house but in mine he's gonna be
distraught he's gonna be sad he's gonna
be happy cat's like i don't give up yeah
dude that doesn't personally bother me
though that's kind of because i know it
looks like it's triggering for you a
little bit right no because i accept the
fact that these are they're evolved in
different ways dogs were bred to work
with us yes cats are like we'll hang out
as long as there's food correct and just
be killing machines yeah the same
essentially as as when we first worked
like like they're the most efficient
killers
the most bird populations
in hawaii
like they're the most efficient killers
that we have yeah yeah like you might
bring cats
apparently it's like a huge deal because
they've millions of birds like there's a
cat of the bird holocaust in hawaii
because of cats yeah and they also i
found that it wasn't a raccoon it was a
[__] cat to kill my [__] koi am i
[__]
hilda my [__] turtle did you put the
did you hear that punish it
i did replenish it also and now they
hang they hang deep so no one can see
them so there's no point now yeah no but
we also put to keep the cat away we put
we spray there's a concoction of hot
pepper you get like hot ghost pepper
water and you spray it and the cats will
be get away from it you know what's
interesting when you call the cats like
they will respond to your voice from far
away and that's also they're going to
argue it's a food call because you only
make certain calls when but like they
will run crocodiles will come after the
boats yeah costa rica because they know
the other condition like a certain sound
or
they associate with right like i don't
think that's actually
particularly special but you do just see
trust that you build up where they come
to you for non-food things to cuddle or
whatever so as long as there's that as
long as you're affectionate with me and
you're good i get my part of the
dynamic out there
yeah exactly well i mean also like
scientists talk about how dogs evolved
to manipulate you they're hunters
scavengers and animals yeah and so they
know that they've evolved to keep their
ears down wag at you because they're
going to get all the goodies yeah so you
can look at everything like that but i
also will say have you ever seen the
they put like a cam on top of a dog's
head and you leave it alone for the work
day and the dog is like
like you're like god damn i feel bad
because dogs want to be around their
husbands so much they're packing that
it's like school yeah and cats really
understand yeah see a dude right they're
solitary yeah
and then also their [__] are out 24
7. yeah which bothers me yeah i like to
give them a tap on the [__] just go
like they're like well you know hey
what's up march the cat guy yeah
chin i feel like you could get uh a dog
of some sort a little lonely over there
now
right i've always wanted that vibe i've
always wanted to have dogs i've had dogs
but as far as like living on my own yeah
i've always wanted to have a dream dog
after seeing joe rogan's freaking golden
retriever i want like a lab or a retreat
yeah just a sweet those are fun yeah
that'd be cool would it be tough because
i'm if i'm at work i feel bad i'm not
bring him here yeah dude i'll bring him
here i like that we do that bring him or
her
i like australian cattle dogs [__]
shepherds oh yeah rats dude shepherd's
like because you you can play tag with
them like if you give them a confined
space i like all you can play you can
chase them or they'll chase you if you
get the right german shepherd it's a
[__] yeah they're great
i like all animals yeah me too
hyenas
but you can train us too people there's
a guy in india you can have a friend
they love them
the same guy who works with the uh the
lions in south africa and he'll like do
a video with them you have to like
establish your dominance in the right
way he plays with them right and he'll
like grab him by the hip so like get him
right here and like he goes i displayed
dominance over them by grabbing them by
their hips and kind of like it's just a
bad mom there
that's just bad
bite the [__] out that's just insane
when i see stuff like that
that's the [__] i'm talking about i
think that's nigeria yeah you guys know
about the uh the gender reversal stuff
with hyenas right
yep
are there hermaphrodites or something
dude you don't want to [__] with a hyena
they will
[__] you up yeah their jaws are super
powerful i mean if you have them if you
have a place that you if you understand
their behavior i guess i don't think so
there is a guy who works with them and i
think if you can understand any like
behavioral dynamic of
an animal
you're going to be
much better
but if you don't they're going to murder
you ass first baby
oh god and they will eat the [__] but
especially if you're if you get them
from a young age like if you get high in
the cubs it's like that's all they know
that you're the leader jim go back to
that guy uh with the one with the mat on
the street or that the the gentleman in
front of the house with the you see it
right here black guy with a hat on
and he's in all white he's like in a
white shirt yeah okay click on that look
at that that's gonna be me that's good
now you guys your face brian that's fine
not my face here's your face got my face
but look at that thing i was talking to
a guy who looked old and i was like man
he's old i look at his face like hold
you guys i'm 52. i was like same
same yeah
that's a cool look though look at that
[__] ridge yeah no one's gonna [__]
you just release the mask and it's game
on
[__] crazy you gotta have a muzzle on
that thing that makes me think that he
probably does bite
oh you think yeah they got and their
mouths are super dirty because they eat
a whole bunch of like rotting food they
can remember the whole narrative of
dog's mouth is cleaner than humans yeah
that's fake
whoa yeah how could it possibly be right
although do you let a dog lick your face
put the food in your mouth
i wouldn't do that on principle i don't
like it it's dumb that right there yeah
i just [__] mad
like if you didn't know the hyena trick
[__] off i'm not doing it yeah oh my god
look at that one that that guy killed
yeah that's a suit that's uh not real
super important i think that's fake yeah
or there's he's just sitting way behind
him they're not that big yeah that's
that's so funny but i mean
i think a hyena can be get up to 170
pounds it's a huge animal dog yeah the
next one
think about that oh b are you going to
delete his wedding
i'm going to be in greece oh that's
right you're missing it yeah where are
you are you going to go oh yeah great
yeah good friend actually good friend no
i didn't no but
thank you
i tried to change my ticket
[Applause]
i called him
i called him yesterday he didn't answer
i just got a call yeah right
not answering
yes you calm down you're not coming to
the wedding yeah he knows why you're
calling so then i said and i said you
better answer or and then i have my baby
then i had my hand up like that he's
like don't do that i go you're making me
mad dude you better answer yeah i think
most people are staying down there i'm
just driving up for the day and then
driving back in there yeah be easy good
i'm glad you're going to be there
what are you looking forward to about
greece by the way
um
you know before right i live there
um i'm going to go to the through the
islands on an amazing yacht and it's all
for free for me oh yeah it's really cool
so i i couldn't it's like one of the
most beautiful places in the world right
so i'm like all right i'm not big on
vacation dude yeah i don't like vacation
it's hard to get me away for a week it's
always like all right i still don't like
when it's free i always feel kind of
like a [__]
right
i can get over that
it depends on i'll cook for you vacation
is and how how expensive it is and how
free yeah but you know because in your
head you know how much it is even if
those guys bawling you're like
yeah and then you're like yo let me get
this mail and he's like
yeah yeah yeah i guess yeah he's a very
generous guy because you're not going to
touch your wallet i was like you know
it's hard to say no and i like him i
actually like him a lot so
he's a good guy people offer brendan
like you know because i'll see uh like
people like here's this amazing vacation
i just want you to spend the night in it
never meet the team like yeah sounds
great right brandon you're like no way
yeah i've forgotten nothing's free yeah
right i've got no i'll be doing a
podcast while you guys have a great time
you lose your [__] kidney yeah no i i
just don't want to do it i don't want
anything given i don't want to do it
nothing it's weird
you just have nothing three yeah it's
always interesting yeah it's weird i
don't want to be in this book have you
ever been groomed
by a man
to have sex with his wife never i am
never once it doesn't take i don't
entertain me yeah that's never happened
to you i don't entertain it they
wouldn't no they they can't even get in
the front door no i'm good
my my buddy had that happen to me it to
him to me but he's a good looking dude
like really good looking and he had he
had this guy approach him and it was
really weird he was like what do you
want me to do how would you even go
about grooming someone when you say
groom you mean asked him to [__] his
wife yeah he wanted to watch
i mean i've had a like meet and greet
that'll be like a hot
wife and the guy in the back what are
you doing after this and then you get
that vibe right oh yeah i'll be like
nothing i've got that yeah yes and then
you're like but mark he's free
my hairy friend over there definitely i
know what you're looking for let's just
cut to the chase
big time like big time recently which
was really interesting i was like if
you're going to choose anybody why are
you going to go with the 55 year old guy
who's losing his hair you know what i
mean because you know what a [__] yeah
obviously and his
yeah his lady was big gal big boned gal
some you know what some nerve hey bubba
yeah that's why they went with you do
you think
because that was what they could get
they don't want big on big hey man
that's not nice of you you're being mean
well you know why though right that's
being mean i know because those people
didn't come to me because i'm like come
on right
with you they're like
no i take the scraps no she was
attracted to me
yeah and then and then uh she kind of
like i noticed her you know smiling and
moving towards me because i got this
vibe and smiling and kind of like
and then standing there i was talking
other people and i just [__]
bolted yeah it was really it was it was
rather weary hotel room that's right and
then she tossed me around like a baton
it was really but it was that i thought
i figured you would get a lot of that
and i don't really entertain it yeah
it'd be tough yeah you don't no you
don't go i don't give that vibe either i
don't do anything no i don't i just go
back to the hotel you people invite you
out you're like oh we're going to the
strip club we're going to this party
like yeah
we're going to watch youtube videos at
the airbnb yeah how's that drink some
whiskey
i get tired at the end of my two shows
now i used to be rearing again i'm
almost upset i'm friends i don't want to
talk all night i just got done doing
stand-up the people i want to talk to
are here man i'm good
that's fair especially you know it's
like yeah i just started podcasting like
to be honest i understand it like you've
been with a girl like of course 12 years
no judgment all of a sudden you're like
we don't want to cheat on each other but
we just shake it up shake it up go do a
little shake there's a whole article on
uh new york post about this couple how
uh
swinging's getting even bigger because
people are starting to be more
open-minded sure
strikes land to latina and she's not too
high on the idea but no in general other
people are yeah you know
yes
yeah i was watching a youtube show this
woman interviews people who are in the
lifestyle just fascinating stuff because
you're like you get to hear the whole
story of like how'd you get into this
and some of it is like
you know the two people might be on the
same page but they don't know like
somebody breaks the ice of like look i
had this idea and then like that sounds
awesome like yeah i'll watch you get
yeah it's dicey isn't it though because
yes
oh you know you didn't want that at all
i know you want a divorce she might
start really enjoying it or what
something happens in that situation
where the guy just shows up and he's
just out right now oh big jake derrick
and she's like i'm going over derrick's
skin here yeah yeah four times this week
yeah and that happens that'll happen but
then it wouldn't be the end of the world
if his wife is just banging like cool
she's coming over here yeah yeah yeah i
don't know dude i don't know
you're playing with fire but also that's
why you have a couple's therapy like i
slipped the therapist a hundred bucks
but i came bring up uh bring up seeing
other people but staying together a
little bit there's a woman who wrote a
book about and then i'll just go should
bring elbow oh man i wouldn't thought
about that there was a wait for her to
answer there was a marriage counselor
brought that up she her husband
was [__] around on her
and then she kind of said well let me
see where i can take this
and then they kind of went like she got
involved in it and found that the
marriage had gotten stagnant and boring
and
it was exactly that jealousy and that
charge was exactly what they needed to
go are we either going to run are we
going to [__] work on this because
something's missing and let's figure out
how to plug the whole tag team this girl
and she wrote a book about it how like
sometimes when she's [__] talking to
a couple and the guy's not interested at
all a lot of times the guy he'll she'll
say go ahead and start looking at other
men and uh maybe uh just see how you're
gonna be threatened or even have an
affair and see what the [__] happens you
know i don't know if it's good advice
but it's awful advice guys will wake the
[__] up maybe you know you take
advantage of people you just take
yourself or your spouse for granted the
world is competitive
if you're willing to girls
yeah hell yeah the million guys knocked
out the door right like
a million guys
that's how it happens i think one one
partner gets lazy as [__] and the other
partner's like otherwise just bored you
know and just
wants the attention from the other
person yeah but you're right in that it
seems to for many of these stories the
spark was provided and that opens up
an avenue to refresh things in the
relationship where it might have ended
because of boredom where you feel
something's missing and that fork in the
road presents itself you take this and
it actually does lead to a progression
of the relationship mark i feel like you
would have an open mind where you could
be an open relationship yeah i wouldn't
like open per se when people say that
broadly it's like
you know you could be involved yeah like
i think for each person involved but if
the guy was i'm more shredded than you
i'm open-minded you know i always tell
people i'm jealous but i am competitive
so it's back oh yeah yeah you think you
should have watched this give me a week
i'll [__] get down
for it though yeah like it just because
i don't you know when you don't have any
moralistic judgments against it like i
wasn't raised to think like this is
wrong but in general i think for most
people monogamy probably works just
because it's easiest yeah and jordan
peterson has some great like in insight
on why that works as a society because
if it wasn't monogamy guess what one
percent of the dudes would be [__]
everybody like drake would have you know
a thousand chicks
yeah but freud said that human beings
are naturally polyamorous like freud
said that they're that human beings
including women but especially men but
but human beings never know if you
really gave them the option yeah and
there were no taboos we'd be [__] the
way chimps do chimps [__] yeah they
don't discriminate they [__] whoever the
females are just as promiscuous
become so ostracized and like so well
that's because it's taboo
yeah your father was who the son was man
but even that it's like it's because the
media has made it like you know someone
gets caught cheating on someone like
this guy's a terrible person yeah i'm
always like yeah who knows what he's
dealing with you don't know what he's
doing yeah who knows but yeah but since
that's such a
universal human tendency
the idea the the idea is with
restriction monogamy and sticking to one
person chaining yourself that one person
and dealing with all the societal
pressures to stay that way and faithful
yeah what's the upside to that
it's like well look at the divorce rate
yeah 53 i think everybody should have a
negotiation where it's like figure out
because open relationship implies like
i'm dating whoever and you're dating
whoever seems a bit mess and stopped but
what if you're like hey once a month we
arrange something we talk about it you
have to really trust each other to like
negotiate like what are the rules what
are the boundaries for what still feels
weird right it does it's like it just
it's adding so much more complexity to
something where it's simple to have one
is it cool if i do it but you don't you
know but a lot of cultures still in this
country especially like immigrant
cultures you don't get divorced you have
kids oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can't get in there no no you're
staying there's a guy a camera who they
might have been armenian from the old
country or turkish i can't remember and
he wanted to get divorced he was
american
and the [__] men from her family
they sat him down they go hey listen
dude all good because they have kids
yeah you can do whatever the [__] you
want you're not leaving and if you do
it's going to be a [__] war
and it was like he was like oh [__] and
he realized that this is about being
involved though like that's not very
involved like dude it's toxic she hits
me yeah we'll be fighting for them but
they said figure it out we'll do
whatever we have to help you figure it
out but you got to figure it out that's
such an old school mentality like some
people aren't meant to be together one
person evolves and grows up and wants
other things and they don't need to be
together yeah like some people are
better people grow beyond yeah you're
right one person
presents themselves as somebody that you
did and then all of a sudden you go wait
you're not the person i thought you were
or you've been together ten years and
you grow apart yeah you grow apart and
your your interests have changed and
they've stayed the same you're like hey
man not working yeah
like i can't believe my parents got
married i have no clue what they're
sipping on or smoking like they're
complete opposite complete options
complete opposites yeah
who just want to go i'm you know
my parents talked about like just
getting out from their own parents thumb
you know what i mean because you're like
you can't leave the house until you're
married or whatever it's like part of
that is but would you be would you do
you think marriage people would take
marriage very differently if divorce was
never an option right so some societies
like i think in ireland there were guys
illegal most guys literally married then
right well they do though because what
happens is in like i would see when when
divorce was illegal in ireland up until
very recently which is crazy
and and think about this so so it's like
there are countries where they don't
allow you to do that right and so
and and so then you would choose very
differently i think you'd be really
careful about getting married and also
modern like 1995 b
there you go how about that how crazy is
that dude but in the philippines it's
still happening apparently in the
philippines that's not
very catholic country by the way except
philippines very catholic country
then again in the old country like in
europe and italy in those countries it's
frowned upon no and when you had when
you couldn't get divorced and you hadn't
you were married no matter what
our body
our body had little something on the
side really it was an institution
like in france in italy in those old
school countries you
you did not get criticized for
stepping out was just something that
would happen the norm
yeah as the sopranos would say a gumma
yes
oh do you watch that doc mark by chance
which oh no no yeah yeah mormon i will
though uh
the was it latter day saw people
commenting online that it was really
good yeah
oh dude i saw it though i saw the
preview for it i was going to get it no
it's good yeah that guy's such a he
looks like such a psycho complete are
you are you over oh yeah four part
series
short like 40 minutes each
do you do you ever get into ozarks oh
yeah
did you watch the last yeah yeah it's
been a while yeah yeah yeah are you all
caught up or no no
oh well i know so good
yeah
jason bateman directed that thing he's a
beast he's phenomenal
all right jim what do you got
hey b let's take a little break from
chatting about so many interesting
things and before we get into this
hot read dude
next week june 22nd next wednesday it's
shaub and friends i got adam carolla
trevor wallace jeff dye named some other
monsters and surprise guests june 22nd
once you're on the hollywood improv
that's next wednesday at 8 pm and then
the trash panda summer tour continues
your boys back on the road fort wayne
indiana is july 14th through the 16th
new club
san diego is the laugh factory san diego
in the heart of downtown san diego july
21st to the 23rd then i end the trash
pan of summer tour in baltimore august
4th through the 6th appleton wisconsin
just got added september 8th through the
10th get your ticket at
thickboy.com and also we're doing a
father's day sale this friday through
sunday you get about 20 off all your
daddies out there even out of debt and
use the sale that's thinkboy.com all the
merchants on sale for father's day get
you some check out
check out best of on youtube kids uh i'm
on my second episode it's doing well i'm
hunting brian callan
brian call on youtube uh best of and i
got milwaukee improv july 21 22 23
brookfield wisconsin austin texas cap
cities july 28 29 30. nashville
tennessee zany's august 25 27.
listen here's the bottom line you take
care of your body fine but your head you
need good health in your head mental
illness is nothing to shake a stick out
nothing be ashamed of sometimes you just
you got burnout sometimes you're just
depressed you don't know why sometimes
you have no motivation you need
professional help you can't just keep
talking to your friends but then but
therapy when you go to a therapist it's
so expensive it's so time consuming you
have online therapy yes better help
therapy with better health and i use it
yeah it's great it really is this
customized online therapy that you can
talk to somebody if you have video on
your phone
when it works for you and they can
connect you to a licensed therapist
somebody really knows what they're doing
in under 48 professional and also you
got to take you got to make yourself a
priority that's what this is man therapy
is making yourself a priority because if
you're your best version they can help
other people out even more better help
is customized online therapy that offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours
the listeners and viewers of the final
kid get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com fighter that's better
h-e-l-p dot com slash fighter
all right wait let me ask a brian
question real quick go ahead so brian
this is a personal question i'm just
curious because you're what 55 56 right
now 55 55.
so
you don't have to answer this question
but how often do you have sex with your
girl at 55 well i'm probably the wrong
guy to ask i'm just curious no because i
know you're like very virile you said
you never had issues with yeah
you i'll let you ask i'm gonna because
if i tell you you won't believe me but
i'll let you ask that question of her
but i i in other words like like
a 55 virus say i have sex with my girl
pretty much every day you'd be like what
it's not in the morning or the night but
yes that's what i do pretty much every
day then yeah but i i love her and i'm
i'm attracted to her and all that and
she's down to do it every single day
yeah because
you know she's 32 and she's down it's
it's it's just damn right that is
impressive i know i'm a [__] that's
impressive a lot of guys the limiting
factor is just like
i can't get hard and i don't have any
sexual desire it's surprising to me how
many
women will say
it's the guy who doesn't have sexual
desire i love her i love the [__] out of
my girl and i also respect her like i
love her and i love everything about her
yeah and
she's one of those gals that also looks
i happen to think unbelievable when
she's not wearing clothes so i'll see
her i'll see her and i'll be like whoa
whoa whoa whoa what the [__] is this you
know and then i'm but i again
that that's why like i want to do
testosterone i want to do trt she's like
you're not [__] doing any of that
yeah not till you need to until that
comes down your energy you seem all
right but a lot of it's like it's not i
don't know if it's testosterone a lot of
it's just it it's
it's also a mindset like how much do you
like
you know how long although it's all that
[__] man yeah why are you asking chin
i'm just curious because brian's 55 and
like i wouldn't have sex that often yeah
but also have you ever had issues ever
not one time you couldn't get it or not
i've never not once no that's impressive
too well that's just something that's
probably genetic yeah
i mean he knows like i've always have
energy i mean that's one thing you used
to always say because i don't know how
you have that much energy yeah but i
have a lot of energy and if i'm not
working out
the other thing is i sleep but but if i
don't work out so so if i'm just
living and i'm just hanging out and
working but i'm not working out i need
very little sleep
i can go i can i wake up after six hours
but if i'm working out i need my seven
and a half
so i haven't pretty good can you have
erectile dysfunction problems no but
it's it's happened sure yeah sure it's
happened to you too right oh yeah yeah
so i'm just surprised that brian at 55.
yeah it depends too you know you've been
an athlete for forever sometimes your
testosterone glow from that head injury
can do that there's a lot of stuff
alcohol and also just being yeah also
but by the way what other people don't
talk about also is that sometimes you
just as you get older as a man your
head's in other places
sex is not the driving factor wait do
you have kids chin like i mean you're my
girl exhausted it's not that sexy when
you have kids it's also all good like we
have it's like yeah you know we tried
yeah and you kind of have to carve out
time for it too it's like if you leave
it to like all right we're gonna go on a
date and watch the movie at 11 p.m i'm
supposed to marriage is not that
romantic or sexy a lot of times
especially when we have kids yeah and
you're working all the time how long
have you been married
uh what four years but we've been
together like almost eight nine yeah a
long time it's a good run it's it's just
gonna it's gonna take on a different
form you know and i i think stress is a
huge
discipline too your girl looks as good
as right now she ever has
but you know it's
what it is
hopefully that helped jen what else you
got
i think it's going to help a lot of
younger or even like
younger guys in their 30s 40s if your
weiner don't work don't be mad man yeah
every now and then it's not going to
work for most for what 50 or 60 percent
after 40 or something like that that's
it's pretty crazy you know a lot of guys
my age and younger who who have to do
the old blue chew or violence yeah a lot
i don't think that's a function i think
that's a function of other things i know
everything else in your life like i said
stress is a huge percentage not the girl
but the time try telling the girl that
yeah i know they take your personal
thank you
but sometimes sometimes you just
sometimes i think a lot of guys have
anxiety uh performance anxiety yeah
especially if it happens once you're
freaking out it's gonna happen again
yeah oh it's just a cycle
yeah and then and then how do you
explain that like you can get into your
head right quick that's something you
have to worry about yeah
you know that's happened that happened
to me
i didn't want to have sex with somebody
and
and i remember i was like what am i
going to do here this is a [__] and
she was a smoker you didn't want to have
sex with you no i was thinking about
somebody else i was in love with who
going through a breakup and i and i
i she was so hot
god damn she was hot you're weiner just
i was a young man and your wiener was
like no my dick wouldn't do it dude yeah
when the when that dick did there's
nothing in there and i got into my head
yeah that's even worse yeah now i'm like
holy cause you have to go completely
relaxed and like reset yourself the
moment you go okay come on come on you
can do it dude that i was it's like if i
could just have 30 seconds of the
bathroom put some newborn on it even
then yeah that'll work
if i don't get out there soon you're
gonna knock on you know whatever oh
what am i gonna do
i'll think sick i'm so embarrassed i'll
i'll fake come i don't know oh yeah
and then you can be having sex and which
again i finally got it going i was
having sex and then i got him and then
he goes then he goes limp and while
you're in what if i can't keep doing
this
it's a vicious cycle and your wiener's
all soft it's so embarrassing i'm sorry
women don't have that they can just i
know
no no they don't know they can pretend
your dick is the biggest best thing in
the world yep
when i say that though they always say
that everybody got you see what happened
to the room because every one of us lost
our energy at this conversation because
we every guy listening knows what the
[__] yeah everybody's every guy should
be on like if you if that has ever been
a possibility for you in your life
i just take cialis like liquid cialis
from lra labs
you order without a prescription so you
can all get this for 50 bucks or less
and you just take a little bit each day
it's not like a viagra you have to take
beforehand
cialis is like 36 hours yeah you know so
it's just a mild thing around the clock
where you never have to plan for it it's
just like but let me ask you this i've
heard you take it every day
yeah yeah potentially it doesn't like
stop working huh it's good for working
out like yeah but steroids and stuff and
and testosterone long-term use can
actually from what i hear can you mess
with your wiener right yeah 100 yeah but
right it kills you yes it's extra to a
little bit and then yeah it would be
related to testosterone and now some
things like
on the low end and on the high end
because if you're producing too much
estrogen you know so you're keeping
these hormones in balance if you just
stop taking it sure
if you don't take a post-cycle therapy
after your cycle but in theory being on
androgens should increase your sex drive
it's just when you have too much in your
system and you're not controlling the
conversion to progesterone or estrogen
estradiol that's what we have problems
yes so like certain certain things like
they say like trend dick or decade these
are two compounds that convert to
progesterone
and uh it's my understanding that those
are two
you know hormones that in abundance kill
your sex drive more than
estrogen for example and you want to
like if your estrogen's too low because
you crush it uh that can also create sex
drive issues because people take
anti-estrogens to look drier if you're
bodybuilder if you crash it too low
you're going to feel like [__] actually
you need a little estrogen for happiness
and like neuro you know protection
so
i'll take care of that wiener man what
do you got jim
all right
um let's take care of that wiener dude
you feel me kind of like you gotta wrap
it up yeah i think he got bored take
care of that wiener man gotta take out
our winner what else we got yeah i think
a lot of dudes would be happy that we
were talking about this yeah yeah of
course we have an issue and that's fine
hey man that's all good dude we've been
saying it
and the real you know trick is you take
cialis and viagra at the same time like
then you're like i think he's doing
every day that's like
because
of all the [__] i take it's the like the
least side effects
aggregate causes some inflammation maybe
in your nasal pads it don't open all the
blood vessels at once you're like whoa
you know
um
so cialis is more mild but again you got
a lot of stuff running in your body i
know mark is just okay mark isn't
walking he's all chemicals
he's a lot of you know
[Music]
taking taking a little bit of cialis
every day is like the least of my
concerns you know so for anybody think
it's dangerous it's like oh no it's
going to open your blood vessels up a
little bit you know
how many if you can count how many
substances you have running through your
body right oh my gosh
caffeine testosterone caffeine a
microdose of mushrooms shout out to my
buddy anthony o'brien
um
testosterone i haven't taken hgh for a
little bit but you know that that's on
the menu on the menu um
but no i'm not that many i'm not taking
very many anabolics right now because
i'm on a you know cruise you're not
taking very many very many yeah i'm
basically natural right now that's what
i'm saying very much
basically naturally are you running any
anavar no you're not at the moment now
you would have told you that man all
right jim what do you got no
you're not on that stuff dude bro all
right testing hdh it's basically natural
right
all right there's a harry styles concert
and someone fell 35 feet from a
vip box and apparently he's just leaning
on it i'll just show you the video here
it's the video kind of sucks
uh he survived he was on a ventilator
for a while but apparently he only has
bro oh no zero broken bones a concussion
and like scrapes or something was he a
big guy he was a young guy like 20
something years old so oh he's that
[__] please tell me when your current
report
events is bts broke up
no that's not i didn't know this oh wow
all right so wow you call yourself
korean hey man i knew this i don't want
to put the music on too much but you'll
see like they'll show they'll show you
like a little
it's right there you see his legs oh oh
falling
from 35 feet using the vip box you say
i think that yeah vip box did harry
style stop the concert he didn't realize
it it happened a lot of people didn't
realize it happened but then apparently
he fell down and there's no one
underneath him luckily because he could
have easily killed someone who fell on
him
damn no broken bones nothing no broken
bones yeah that's it
wow so two black eyes concussion and
bruises that's it all right not even
scrapes bruises jesus christ
yeah wow so he's lucky to be alive but
uh and he apparently said like he was
leaning on the thing that's the last
thing you remember he was leaning on it
and he thought it was really low
and then boom he woke up to like people
like god damn what he means he's super
lucky yeah
um this i thought was super interesting
tell me if you've seen this mark oh yeah
love this okay so this is more plates
more dates he was covering this girl
i guess she's a tick-tocker she started
filming herself and she blamed this guy
of being a pervert because he literally
the guy that works there too you just
did this you'll see him and she edited
the video in a certain way i'll play
this first she said it blew up in her
face she's accusing me yeah the black
guy who's standing up in the background
not the one who's lifting yeah
she's accusing him just to clarify
because it's hard to see even what the
[__] she's talking about but i hit him
with like perving on her yeah and when i
stand up for myself he threatens to call
the police and revoke my
membership
so she edited this video and it slowed
down here
[Music]
was she timing so this guy turns and she
put the subtitles oh damn when
we don't know if he said that
do you need
something
do you need something
okay i thought so
jesus christ lady sucks
[Music]
keep it pushing keep me pushing she
thinks she's all hot
so i saw this video as well this is
actually the video of her the entire
video um this is ray william johnson's
tick tock this was handled so poorly
trainer gets caught on camera being a
pervert and when i stand up for myself
he threatens to call the police and
revoke my membership
do you need something
and he's like
what no she's such an [__]
but it's also not like she's a 10 either
right
she sucks
his knees like my grandma
okay
all right and it's girls that aren't the
tens that are always like
big people are hitting
okay i understand that women have to put
up with a lot in situations like these
but the video doesn't show anything more
than a glance and then we get right into
do you need something to then blasting
their face on the internet and calling
them a pervert
pointing out that she slowed the footage
down so this look is actually yeah he
must have just done that yeah yeah she
might have he added the caption oh damn
when clearly his mouth is moving way too
much to have said oh damn he's talking
to his friend mid sentence when he
turned around now i don't know if these
dudes were checking her out or not but
as someone who makes videos when you set
up a camera and record yourself in
public people stare doesn't mean they
want to [__] me or maybe they do want to
[__] me i don't know this was handled so
poorly so more more place more dates is
like
just like all of us if we saw like a hot
girl of course
this girl said but that's it no she's
just looking for attention calling him a
pervert but by the way yeah that's don't
just choose somebody for that that's
what i'm saying that's that's the shitty
part yeah i mean it's defamation but
then also
like
she's obviously looking for attention
yeah yeah
hey sweetie i hate to tell you yeah
there's real hot girls who really get
gawked at the gym hey hey
you're not one of them yeah yeah you're
you're la-4 you're a young brian callum
as a girl okay and i never i wasn't
getting she's not bad but i mean she's
all right
young brian
yeah
i was you know what when i was her age i
wasn't bad that's what i got she's all
okay everybody i know big deal i'm dead
lifting you see my ass like whoa there
are still you ain't [__] you sent me to
a gym in miami you're in l.a oh my god
like a bridge troll yeah she sucks
uh how about this mark i love this oh i
was hoping the dog's caught up all right
just for entertainment it would probably
be nice to the dog no no no no a stray
dog is lucky to be alive after
that [__] thing in a less than
familiar environment
my thing is how'd the [__] dog get in
there
yeah i don't know how he got in there
either
apparently he didn't even have a chip or
a collar or nothing oh no
apparently the zoo told all the parents
that uh take the kids away because they
thought the gorilla's gonna work yeah
which i would think i would think that
same thing my son would have been crunk
is that san diego's but oh my god
what happened to the dog nothing that's
the problem with the video but watch
this part yeah watch this
it's a little
i don't think that that chimp is just
trying to protect his family yeah i mean
that that silverback
there's only two of them in there yeah
how is that right yeah two adults yeah
they don't keep the females in the film
here we go here we go
oh
and the dog apparently goes down a
little he just threw some bubbles at him
she's kind of hype
[Music]
it [__]
yeah it's a super boring video i wish
there was more to it um it was like
listen it was on ktla it went like that
he went like this
because he didn't know what else to do
oh my god
do you guys remember who uh julius
francis was sure what he fought mike
tyson oh wow i think two thousand he's a
security guard and someone talk [__]
though oh let me see this uh no so i'll
show you this video is kind of
interesting i love this it's not like
watch
so this guy's causing trouble got the
blue headband
this looks like it's in brooklyn oh it's
actually in the uk oh outside of wembley
no he's actually on the outside you'll
see and tell me what you think this how
this actually ends or what do you think
of him doing what he did
so
he's already outside the building now
rushing people this guy punches him yeah
but
watch this right here watch here
that's the boxer
he just knocked him out yeah when he
started talking he started talking the
thing is he's making an aggressive move
of course he looks towards the security
guard you can kind of see his hand go
48 professional fights yeah you're not
that's a lot of fights but now he's
working security yeah he ain't doing
[__] again now he had a tough career 23
and 24 but to that guy he's still a
different [__] muhammad ali correct
57 year old former futurist you [__]
klitschko okay
it's a lot of fighting
all right so this is a another
excerpt on the amanda heard stuff how
she spoke out after the the trial and
the thing that she says that bothers me
a lot you'll see right here
the depth lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
it's good come back
i'll play it for you one more time come
back people are saying death lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
[Music]
pirate ship
the host is all
uh no that's not what they're saying
i got it all i got an argument this
morning with a guy who i've known a long
time who said well you know johnny depp
beat her up i go no he did where are you
coming up with that he goes yeah dude
come on he beat her up i mean you know
he beat her up and so then that's just
misogyny and i go
what are you talking about i didn't
anything that's your friend
when i tell you you understand he goes i
don't he goes i don't
he said something fact he goes i don't
um i didn't watch the i didn't follow
the trial i go well i did so you just
read well i did
you just being amber yeah i did follow
it closely what are you [__] saying i
have any relevant information but i got
annoyed this morning man it kind of
ruined my day i almost called you i got
i'm glad you did it i got mad hopefully
i don't know
it's funny you found like the one
percent of the population that still
believes that johnny depp no i like it
and i'm like
i was really surprised i'm like hey bro
we've been friends a long time you're
saying some dumb [__] here yeah that
bummed me out i got mad today it kind of
ruined my morning i was like this i went
all right i'll see you later
click [__] that here we go
oh nice missing i'm just fascinated by
bam margera did you guys ever see his
doctor phil appearance yes dude
i mean you know heartbreak is a huge
train wreck but the guy doesn't take
responsibility for anything
drug addict multiple time rehab that's
why it can be in the new jackass because
they said you gotta obey by the drug
drug testing yeah and he wouldn't do it
yeah
and he was making you know he frames
everything as being unfair and it's this
person's fault my mom i created this
like how can you guys leave me out there
like dude we're trying to help you get
sober yeah but it is it's a good case
study of narcissism because you're like
oh this guy
truly projects responsibility to
everyone around him takes no ownership
taken zero ownership and now he's
missing yeah so cops are on the lookout
for ben margera after he bolted from a
florida rehab facility he wasn't allowed
to leave according to delray beach
police report the rehab facilities
manager reported the jackass star
missing on monday the manager says bam
told him he was unhappy with the place
and their services now is he required by
law to be there
good question
uh that was him he hit the world by the
balls
so much money yeah yes he was under he
was the richest one yeah yeah he was
under a court order
um
uh what's his what's his drug of choice
blow or just everything uh
more than blow sir yeah yeah you
wouldn't be so definitely a lot of
drinking heavy drinking handsome guy
when he's younger huh yes
gee whiz got some blue eyes some baby
blues
he went downhill when his friend died
right yeah remember that that's what
ryan died in a car
yeah in a gt
is that really what happened he just
kind of went
since that happened he just spiraled out
of control it's a heartbreaking
story
last month bam had broken his wrist and
elbowed a skateboarding accident and was
blaming the facility for not setting up
his physical therapy appointment so
again more blame
yeah it's time how old is he probably 45
50. his show on mtv was great too and he
had that wife who now he's not with
anymore she's really pretty too nope
only 42. he's too young he looks a lot
older he does look older yeah um well
okay
i talked to stevo recently what a great
guy steven was great what a great guy
has anybody seen the new jackass i did i
did do you like it it's tough because
they're older right just okay
there's a jackass 4.5 on netflix it's
like behind the scenes they have the new
cast you can tell they're trying to get
more woke
a little tough it almost felt like a lot
of the skits were
a little too fake too yeah yeah yeah
it's also like
there's youtubers doing more gnarly [__]
now man yeah johnny knocked he was like
60 with gray hair y'all all right well
yeah that's right their first few ones
were freaking crazy well i mean johnny
knoxville did the craziest [__] i've
ever seen johnny knoxville when he had
he was had a cigarette in his mouth with
a with a blindfold and they let bulls
down yeah he's like exciting he got
[__] up no he got royally [__] up oh
yeah even bad grandpa's fantastic
fantastic
you know he had the world by the balls
yeah the ringer
men in black what two or three he was in
like johnny knoxville was huge
all right um maybe one more
so ronda rousey apparently this isn't
like really big news but she said she
would still come back to this day to
fight gina carrano because how much she
looked up to yeah i was like she knows
her hero yeah so i forget because
gives ronda the credit but gina was the
first she was the first and she was also
beautiful it was super pretty yeah and
people also forget like they're like oh
when gina fought cyborg she had her ass
what go back and watch that she did
pretty well yeah yeah
what is what is uh ronda rousey doing
now
wrestling wwe basketball she's huge
massive yeah she was the champ for a
while yeah she's massive wow that's like
a rant making way more money than i
don't know she's making more money
because she was right she was the
biggest star other than connor yeah she
made so much money fc yeah she made a
[__] ton of money but if they actually
had this fight now do you guys think it
would be
blockbuster huge or what do you think
ronnie come back would be pretty big
versus gino yeah that'd be big
there's that regina's a little older
though you know i don't know if she'd do
that be fun fight though yeah i think
that that's perfect
out of the game for a while
yeah she's bigger yeah a lot bigger
170 yeah pretty big
ronnie could do it though i mean rounded
yeah
i'd watch it i don't know if it's going
to be a blockbuster but
what 40.
oh yeah
and she's doing a movie right now with
your boy cowboy both of your boys yeah
cowboy serrano and uh
yeah um daily wire yeah they're doing it
western or something they make so much
money i know it's awesome yeah it's out
they're doing promo touring now i'm
trying to get my food
let me do it so she's 40. wow she's so
beautiful so pretty i think she's so hot
oh the hottest female fighter of all
time
or male 1
yeah
and ron is five years younger wow
rhonda's 35
met her 10 years ago bob
old school huh how about that i know
i don't think that fight's gonna come to
fruition though
oh
here we go this is for you brennan
bts yeah
there's well but they also released a
video and it's the saddest video it's
basically them being like what's
happening we're saying goodbye but it's
not forever but they're done so that's
pretty much the same thing right yeah
but they're saying not going on haters
lost in translation yeah oh there's no
there's a sit-down interview two of them
are balling crying it's over yeah but
maybe it was about something all right
they got some uh maybe they're just
having a bad day
no it's like it's like in sync with jade
like that one of them is a timber like
he's like hey i'm going off on my own
i'm out of here they're very they don't
make too much money
as big as they're considering yeah
they are like they're probably getting
they're like ufc fighters their
contracts suck yeah they're kind of
calls yeah they make a billion dollars
and they each get like a million because
they give it all to the korean
government right
i don't know i don't know how how it
works you know that's that's not even
like a real like they're i'm sure
something might be like that but for
sure the record company though the
producer and the record company they
make the majority of the money so what
are they and you know they deserve a lot
of money too because they put all these
people together teach them how to do all
this stuff and
everything so they deserve a lot of
money but uh yeah it's definitely
incredible well look at this so they
announced they're breaking up that says
the the music number that reps bts
reportedly lost 1.7 billion the market
value during the stock trading early
wednesday morning and now they're on a
full back battle over there like hey
boys
let's get the suits back together let's
let's dance huh let's get some out i
wonder if they can renegotiate their
contract though
yeah they should but actually they have
enough power now i think where they
could do it they're so popular they're
so fit each individual person is so
famous that they could probably do it
now if they knew how to be business
people that one on the far right's
[__] if they'll break down
he's the joey photo well i was just
thinking that they're the ones that get
the guy in the middle so the guy the
third in from the left will blow the
[__] up
the rapper the second from the right is
great the target you know what
everyone's great the guy the far guy on
the right is [__] he's 48. well no
he's just he doesn't really sing you're
not you know he's giving me a tough gig
that's a wig and he was the one crying
the most because he knows it's over he
needed the boys
wow seven of them it's kind of sad
yeah crinklers have like freaking nine
people even more that korean work ethic
too they just work their [__] yeah
it's crazy soldiers dude they're so big
are they oh my god they're the biggest
right
at least at some point some argue the
biggest fan of all time yeah yeah
worldwide like so massive yeah
like they had what got it sold out shows
at staples and people were waiting out
no they sold out uh where the rams like
four times and for people trying to get
tickets even though it sold out they
slept outside for like three or four
days in tents and [__] well you got you
gotta you gotta [__] clearly
renegotiate your contract get some of
that coin for yourself before it's all
over
do another two years if they know how to
do that though it's tough especially
korean korean people like even mia would
be they'd be tough well that's what i
was saying like yeah i was going to say
are you allowed no it's not you know
also the owner of the band it was like
hey [__] i could pick seven koreans and
made you guys they saw our mark in like
like who they're producers yeah they're
like it's all our songs they're also
gangsters it's all catchy tunes like
catchy hooks that makes they study all
that they know all that it's all it's
all calculated so they're like oh we'll
find another seven grateful koreans
you're gonna shut your mouth it's also
sponsored we're paying for all your
plastic surgery for people you know what
i'm saying yeah powerful people too and
that that are kind of anonymous you
don't want to [__] with them too much
it's like
oh then they're also going to decide out
of the seven who's going to make it yeah
well i'm telling you right now homeboy
on the right spot yeah they always
usually groups break off into solo and
duos or whatever but then usually one
person's really really famous and then
they just look at one direction harry
styles is like cool story fellas i'm no
longer splitting this pot four ways i'm
gonna go off on my own because i'm
talented right so i'll see you guys
later and become the biggest thing ever
and also [__] olivia wilde okay that's
my story you do have a good day okay i'm
not your
stupid touring van with you because i
like to fart you guys complain all the
time all right
and i'm also going to wear dresses
because i like wearing dresses he's
whatever he wants to do sure
you know
bands have a good time you guys have fun
i like to have sex you have fun
i'll [__] some tens and you guys aren't
gonna be around to judge me because
you're not allowed in my room anymore
right so that's how this works i'm gonna
get really famous and you two are gonna
kind of mosey down the road into
obscurity yeah let's sell this olivia
you guys go on a bike okay see you guys
every single time i tell you a story
where the british uh this exploration
group and they were like you know back
in the day when they were exploring the
routes in the arctic so they just have
to find a way to get their boats around
the arctic
and they were caught and they were
starving to death freezing to death
gangrene and [__]
and the guy knew he was gonna die and he
looked at his men he was the leader of
the expedition
and typically if you're the leader of
exhibition you came from a long line of
aristocracy sure and he looked at them
this is how a brit dies he looked him
and said i'm going for a walk and there
was a there was like blizzard sort of
like you know i'm watching i'm going for
i'm going for a walk my i'm going for a
walk gentlemen
and i may be some time
and he got up and just walked into the
abyss and never died like a judge that
story or do we think it's folklore
that's a fact that story is true
actually because his men recited that
yeah he died he just went but that was
very british oh yeah very upright if
you're going to go out we'll see him
like going in front of
tank was sinking the guy was like well
all right and just stayed there on the
[__]
saluting yeah you do your duty to the
end you could you know
swim a little bit you know you have to
go down the ship that's it you didn't
build this thing that's it world war ii
and world war one there would always be
those stories about the the guy either
got knocked out fell asleep didn't
charge uh uh whatever happened something
happened and uh he would be have to be
shot for cowardice or shot for not doing
his duty and what would happen was the
commanding officer would have a
conversation and explain that it's very
important to keep these things up even
though it wasn't your fault in this case
we have to keep
things you know the status quo
yeah there are a lot of examples where
he would shake hand he would salute his
commanding officer shake his hand and
he'd say thank you for your service and
go off and get shot by his own men yeah
that's that that was the discipline of
the old school that was sort of like the
idea of there is duty you are a small
part of a larger chain of being
well it's like if you watch those
reenactments like civil war if you're on
the front with like a musket
i mean you just fall down you happen to
trip yeah you missed half the battle
half the boys get taken out and then
when you're talking around the campfire
like dude that was crazy like where the
[__] were you brandon
i was there man i was there well stanley
so
you know
i was gonna have a jacket no dude i [__]
i fell and then i was right behind you
well you know you know how when in
trench warfare they'd blow the bugle and
you would have to run to the to the
other trench to take and they would set
their machine's guns up and just shoot
you down as you came so pretty soon guys
like i'm not running i'm not doing this
because i'm going to die for sure so
then you'd have your officer behind you
and if you didn't answer the whistle you
got shot in the back of the head
so you had to tough way to go and in
paths of glory with stanley kubrick
movie
a soldier gets and this is based on real
things he got knocked out he got hit in
the head as they were going to charge
and he was out and he didn't charge and
then there was a whole case about him
being a coward but he's like i got
knocked down what do you want to do and
they're down the road you're still
killed
that would be the case and then they
didn't know what shell shock was back
then they didn't know what that was and
a lot of guys would you wouldn't go to
you you couldn't sleep for 12 days
sometimes there's no sleep
and so then they would go into this you
physically consider video they'd be in
shell shock they their bodies they were
some kid from the farm that the noise
and they would just
and they would [__] because they
didn't know what it was they they they
would be tried
formally and killed for cowardice so
you'd have these guys you know she said
yeah it was really [__] crazy the
more we learn
remember epileptics
they were considered they're like oh
you're having an epileptic seizure you
got the devil in you got to kill you
yeah and that's fair
yeah that is that's the only thing there
that's you know what that on my board
with that's all that on board if i get
knocked down you shoot me and call me a
coward well my kids gotta wear in your
helmet yeah god damn it yeah
well the more you know and then this is
what you do though this is what you do
in world war one you don't want to do
that trench warfare
cigarette
hold your hand up
boom you get your hands shut off
and you're like or you shoot your own
foot oh sniper takes it out and then you
get the and then you're like oh well and
they got and you go medal of honor yeah
thanks they get shot at least i don't
die i lose my hand i don't die damn that
was a lot that happened a lot so if you
had a hand injury
and you were back in civilian life
they'd all kind of look at your side
they'd be like yeah oh they know
something you could smell the front
lines from five miles away apparently
yeah mark
it wasn't a whole lot of time for
exercise yeah well i do remember reading
the descriptions or hearing the
descriptions from that what is it
hardcore history where he describes like
the trenches and how these dudes would
fall in there like oh it's the most
gruesome thing like you're just like
this pit of rotting bodies and
somebody's still alive going like hey
help me out like you guys sucked into
the mud yeah you have all this gear and
you would just get sucked even the
horses you'd get sucked into these
because it would rain and it would be
like quicksand
disappear
[__] bro you know so that kind of
warfare just sounds like speaking of
being in the trenches i'll be in fort
wayne indiana there you go that is july
14th through the 16th fort wayne indiana
and then san diego is the heart of
downtown san diego laugh factory san
diego july 21st to 23rd then we end the
trash panda summer tour baltimore august
4th through the 6th appleton just got
added that is september 8th through the
10th and then next wednesday uh it was
at the 22nd june 22nd wednesday night
8pm i got adam carolla jeff dye trevor
wallace some monsters and a special
guest that is 8 p.m hollywood improv la
that's next wednesday 8 p.m but fort
wayne you're up next july 14th through
16th
tickets at t uh thickboy.com or fhkz.com
also we're doing a thick boy father's
day sale i forget how much percentage
off it's at least 20 percent off for
father's day at thickboy.com no it
starts friday milwaukee improv europe
july 21 22-23 then we got austin texas
the end of the month july 28 29 30. i
can't wait cap city uh nashville
tennessee august 25 27
best of my new youtube show we dropped
the second episode hunting pythons in
the everglades check it out monday is
the next time my the next show that
drops which i think is really good so
come listen come laugh
yeah all right kids love ya
next week brian's in greece yes i am so
we're gonna have to figure it out but we
will all right love you kids we're out